This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. To begin, there's someone our producer Sam Greenspan would like you to meet. Can you say who you are and how you know me? I'm your grandmother. My name is Jean Greenspan and I'm Sam Greenspan's grandmother. Jean Greenspan is my father's mother. I call her Grandma Jeannie. She grew up during the Great Depression and because her family got a lot of help from FDR and the New Deal, Grandma Jeannie is a Democrat. Always has been, always will be. Grandma, have you ever voted for a Republican or anyone who wasn't a Democrat?
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。首先，我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘想让您认识一个人。你能说一下你是谁以及你是怎么认识我的吗？我是你奶奶。我叫吉恩·格林斯潘，我是萨姆·格林斯潘的奶奶。吉恩·格林斯潘是我父亲的母亲。我叫她珍妮奶奶。她在经济大萧条时期长大，由于她的家庭得到了罗斯福总统和新政的大力帮助，珍妮奶奶是一位民主党人。过去是，现在是，将来也是。奶奶，你有没有投过共和党或者任何不是民主党的人？
No, no, no, no, no, no, never, never, never do that. Always vote for a Democrat. And so on the first Tuesday after the first Monday in November in the year 2000, Grandma Jeannie hopped on her three wheel bike and peddled over to the community center in her retirement village and she did what she always does she voted a straight democratic ticket or at least she thought she did grandma can you tell me where you live oh now I live in century village west Palm Beach in Florida and in what county do you live in Palm Beach County an election turmoil, a presidency in the balance, who will emerge the winner in the historic Florida recount.
没有，没有，没有，没有，没有，没有，从来没有，从来没有，从来没有那样做过。总是投票给民主党。所以在2000年11月第一个星期一之后的第一个星期二，珍妮奶奶骑上她的三轮自行车，蹬车来到了她退休村的社区中心，她做了她一直以来都在做的事情：她投了民主党直选票，或者至少她以为自己是这么做的。奶奶，你能告诉我在哪里住吗？哦，现在我住在佛罗里达州西棕榈滩的世纪村。你住在哪个县？棕榈滩县。选举陷入混乱，总统职位悬于一线，谁将在历史性的佛罗里达州重新计票中脱颖而出成为赢家？
I believe the people of Palm Beach County have entrusted us to voice their right to participate in their government. I move that this board conduct a manual recount of all the ballots for the presidential election for the year two. The election was close, but tonight after a count and yet another manual we count, Secretary Cheney and I are honored and humbled to have won the state of Florida, which gives us the needed electoral votes to win the election. As a quick refresher, the 2000 presidential race between Republican George W. Bush and Democrat Al Gore came down to contested votes in Florida.
我相信棕榈滩县的人民已经委托我们来表达他们参与政府治理的权利。我动议该委员会对第二年总统选举的所有选票进行人工重新计票。选举结果非常接近又一次人工重新计票之后，切尼秘书和我深感荣幸和谦卑，我们赢得了佛罗里达州，这给了我们赢得选举所需的选举人票。简单回顾一下，2000年共和党人乔治·W·布什与民主党人阿尔·戈尔之间的总统竞选归结为佛罗里达州的争议选票。
And one of the four counties at the center of the controversy was Palm Beach County. Voters were using paper ballots, where you indicate your choice by punching out holes with a metal stick. Palm Beach County's ballot, known as the Butterfly ballot, had choices of candidates spread over two pages, with the holes to punch out in between them. But some found the layout confusing. Voters who wanted to cast their vote for George W. Bush had no problem. It was clear that the correct hole to punch was the very first one, right at the top.
而处于争议中心的四个县之一就是棕榈滩县。选民使用纸质选票，通过用金属棒戳破孔洞来表明他们的选择。棕榈滩县的选票被称为蝴蝶选票，候选人的选择分布在两页纸上，戳孔在两页之间。但有些人发现这种布局令人困惑。想要投票给乔治·W·布什的选民没有遇到问题。很明显，正确的戳孔是第一个，就在最顶端。
But there was some ambiguity about which was the right hole to punch to indicate a vote for Al Gore. Was it the second one down, right after after Bush or was it the third one down? Gore was actually the third one down. The way the ballot was set up, some voters who believed they were voting for Al Gore actually cast a vote for Patrick Buchanan. Buchanan being the extremely conservative reform party candidate. And there was also a problem with the physical ballots themselves. Namely, the Chads. When you punch a hole in something, the Chad is the little piece of paper or cardboard or whatever it is that gets punched out. And in theory, it should be completely punched
但对于哪个是表明投票给阿尔·戈尔的正确孔洞存在一些含糊不清的地方。是紧随布什之后的第二个，还是倒数第三个？戈尔实际上是倒数第三个。按照选票的设置方式，一些自以为投票给阿尔·戈尔的选民实际上把票投给了帕特·布坎南。布坎南是极度保守的改革党候选人。实体选票本身也存在问题。也就是残片。当你在一件东西上戳一个洞时，残片是被戳出来的小纸片、纸板或其他什么东西，理论上它应该被完全戳
out. But sometimes it just doesn't happen. Sometimes the Chads hang on. And in the case of the 2000 election, if the Chad was still hanging on, the ballot counting machine couldn't always read the ballot. And for the people who would eventually count them by hand in the recount, the auditors had to interpret the intent of the voter, and these hanging chads became quite infamous as well, because in retabulating the vote, you had to make assumptions about whether a hanging Chad was a vote for a particular candidate or it was a mistake. That's Eric Heron. My name is Eric Heron and I'm the Aberdeley family professor of political science at West Virginia University. And I focused my research on elections, electoral systems. And so because of this faulty ballot in Palm Beach County my grandma Jeannie a died in the wool new deal Democrat from the Jewish tenements of New York
掉。但有时它就是不会掉下来。有时残片还挂着。在2000年大选的情况下，如果残片还挂着，计票机就无法总是读取选票。对于那些最终在重新计票中用手清点的人来说，审计员必须解释选民的意图，这些挂着的残片也变得相当有名，因为在重新统计选票时，你必须假设挂着的残片是对特定候选人的投票还是一个错误。那是埃里克·赫伦。我叫埃里克·赫伦，我是西弗吉尼亚大学的阿伯德利家族政治学教授。我的研究重点是选举和选举制度。因此，由于棕榈滩县这个有缺陷的选票，来自纽约犹太人贫民窟的坚定新政民主党人珍妮奶奶
City might have accidentally endorsed a third-party candidate who embraces all the things that she is against and then when we were told I was really embarrassed we felt cheated we felt guilty I felt guilty that I voted for the wrong person. Her retirement community, Century Village, was actually called out by salon.com and other news outlets, as polling unusually high for Pat Buchanan. There's extensive research to show that the votes cast for Buchanan in Palm Beach County were extraordinarily high. They were anomalous in the region and in general, and the best explanation for the spike in support for Patrick Buchanan was the design of the ballot. Even Pat Buchanan himself admitted that his high numbers were probably due to an error.
可能会不小心支持了一个第三党候选人，而这个候选人拥抱了她所反对的一切，当被告知时，我们真的感到很尴尬，我们感到被欺骗，我们感到内疚，我为自己投错了人感到内疚。她的退休社区世纪村甚至被salon.com和其他新闻媒体点名，称其帕特·布坎南的投票率异常高。有广泛的研究表明，棕榈滩县投给布坎南的选票异常高。它们在该地区和总体上都是反常的，对帕特·布坎南支持率飙升的最佳解释是选票的设计。甚至帕特·布坎南本人也承认，他高得惊人的数字可能是由于一个错误造成的。
Now, the Butterfly Ballot was only one small piece of the debacle that was the 2000 election in Florida. A lot of absentee ballots were counted incorrectly, there was a manual recount that was started and then stopped, and later it would come out that the state of Florida wrongfully denied the right to vote to at least 12,000 people, a disproportionate number of whom were people of color. All of this in an election where the margin of victory was fewer than 600 votes. There were a number of incidents in Florida in the 2000 elections that were politically charged and potentially motivated by partisan intent,
现在，蝴蝶选票只是2000年佛罗里达州选举这场惨败的一小部分。许多缺席选票被错误地计算了，人工重新计票开始后又被叫停，后来有消息称佛罗里达州非法剥夺了至少12000人的投票权，其中不成比例的一部分是有色人种。所有这一切都发生在胜利优势不到600票的选举中。2000年佛罗里达州的选举中发生了许多带有政治色彩且可能由党派意图驱动的事件，
but the design of the butterfly ballot is much more likely a case of malpractice than malice. It was a classic design fail. It's a poorly designed ballot. It is a ballot that does not take into account the way that a voter would look at the ballot and use the particular technology in place at the time, punch card technology, to cast their vote.
但蝴蝶选票的设计更有可能是渎职而非恶意。这是一个经典的设计失误。这是一张设计糟糕的选票。这是一张没有考虑到选民如何看待选票并使用当时现有的特定技术（打孔卡技术）来投票的选票。
The ballot is a designed object that is critically important for democracy. But in the United States, it's almost never designed by an actual design professional. And as such, our liberty is being infringed upon by the tyranny of bad design. One of the oldest recorded instances of a vote is from the ancient Greek play The Humanities by Eskolas. In this story, Aresti's is on trial for the murder of his mother. Twelve jurors line up and take turns placing a stone in one urn to signify guilty or in another urn to signify not guilty.
选票是一个对民主至关重要的设计对象。但在美国，它几乎从不由真正的设计专业人士来设计。因此，我们的自由正受到糟糕设计暴政的侵害。有记录以来最早的投票实例之一来自古希腊戏剧埃斯库罗斯的《复仇女神》。在这个故事中，阿瑞斯提斯因谋杀母亲而受审。十二名陪审团成员排成一行，轮流将一块石头放入一个骨灰瓮中以表示有罪，或者放入另一个骨灰瓮中表示无罪。
And this motif of the stone as a marker of a vote, it's an image that's stuck, and the Greek word sephos, which means small stone or pebble, is the root of syphology or the study of elections. And as Eric Heron tells it, himself a syphologist, the whole stone in the earn setup was not too different than how elections in the United States were originally conducted. So in the early US elections, you will find voters casting a voice vote. They physically had to make their way to the polling place and announce their vote. And one of the things you do sacrifices the privacy of your vote. Individuals know who you are voting for. And what that can engender is pressure on voters to support one candidate or another.
石头作为投票标记的主题是一个挥之不去的形象，希腊语sephos意为小石头或卵石，是选举学或选举研究的词根。正如身兼选举学家的埃里克·赫伦所说，骨灰瓮中放石头的整个设定与美国最初举行选举的方式相差无几。所以在早期的美国选举中，你会发现选民进行口头投票。他们必须亲自前往投票点并宣布他们的投票。你所做的事情之一就是牺牲了投票的私密性。个人知道你在投谁的票。这可能会对选民施加压力，迫使他们支持某个候选人。
And the polls were not calm places with orderly lines. You could be bachelored and pressured into voting a certain way. Early elections in the United States often featured liquor and violence and fraud. Voters would have to push or shove or be physical to express their right to vote. In fact, an election could be so raucous that it served as an argument for some against women's suffrage. Elections were deemed as inappropriate for women to attend. Then, in the late 1800s, elections supervisors realized that having people vote by speaking their choices allowed was a terrible idea.
投票站并不是一个排着有序队伍的平静地方。你可能会被拉拢并被迫以某种方式投票。美国早期的选举往往夹杂着酒精、暴力和欺诈。选民必须推搡、挤压或使用肢体来表达他们的投票权。事实上，一场选举可能会如此喧闹，以至于成为反对女性参政的理由。人们认为选举不适合女性参加。然后，在19世纪后期，选举监督员意识到让人们大声说出他们的选择来投票是一个糟糕的主意。
The lack of privacy could lead to coercion, and those who did vote their conscience had no way to verify that their vote was being recorded accurately. And this all led to the advent of the paper ballot called a ticket. But unlike the ballots we have today, these were printed not by the government, but by political parties. Political parties would print their own ballots. That voters would take with them to the polling place. Now these could be printed in newspapers,
缺乏隐私会导致胁迫，而那些凭良心投票的人没有办法验证他们的投票是否被准确记录。这一切导致了被称为选票的纸质选票的出现。但与我们今天的选票不同，这些选票不是由政府印制的，而是由政党印制的。政党会印制自己的选票。选民会把选票带到投票站。这些选票可以印在报纸上，
they could be printed by the parties themselves and distributed, and the voter would turn in that party ticket. The party tickets would generally only have the candidates from that party on them. So if say you wanted mostly Republicans, you go get a Republican party ticket and then you cross out the candidates that you don't want and then either write in or literally cut and paste
它们可以由政党自己印刷并分发，选民将交出该党的选票。政党选票通常只印有该党的候选人。因此，假设你主要想要共和党人，你就去拿一张共和党选票，然后划掉你不想要的候选人，然后写上或者字面意义上剪切并粘贴
pieces of paper with your candidate's names onto that ticket. And this is the origin of the term to cast a split ticket or a straight ticket. But this system also had problems. For one, parties could make tickets that looked like those of their opponents, but actually had their own candidates listed, dooping voters into voting for the wrong party. Non-standard ballots also created other opportunities for shenanigans, like racketeering schemes, which facilitated a whole black market of buying and selling votes.
写有你候选人名字的纸片到那张选票上。这就是分票或直选票术语的起源。但这个系统也有问题。首先，政党可以制作看起来像对手但实际上列出了自己候选人的选票，诱骗选民投错党。非标准选票还为恶作剧创造了其他机会，比如敲诈勒索计划，这促成了买卖选票的整个黑市。
And so the party ticket system wasn't creating fair elections either. So in the late 19th century, there is an innovation that is imported from abroad. It's called the Australian ballot. And the Australian ballot is government printed ballot that is distributed to voters who come to a polling place and they cast their ballot in private. And this Australian ballot system was a game changer. First of all, we started treating ballots more like currency. Administrators have to store them securely.
因此政党选票系统也没有创造公平的选举。所以在19世纪后期，从国外引进了一项创新。它被称为澳大利亚选票。澳大利亚选票是由政府印制的选票，分发给来到投票站并在私密情况下投票的选票。这个澳大利亚选票系统改变了游戏规则。首先，我们开始像对待货币一样对待选票。管理者必须安全地储存它们。
They have to restore them safely. They have to maintain a clear chain of custody over them to maintain the integrity of the election process. They're often printed on special paper to undermine counter-fitting or efforts to commit fraud. And with the Australian ballot as a point of departure, polling places in the US began to see new machines that interfaced with the official government printed ballots.
他们必须安全地恢复它们。他们必须对它们保持清晰的监管链，以维护选举过程的完整性。它们通常印在特殊的纸张上，以破坏伪造或实施欺诈的企图。以澳大利亚选票为出发点，美国的投票站开始出现与官方政府印制选票相连接的新机器。
There were machines where you pull levers or use a metal rod to punch holes out of an optical scan ballot. Like we saw with the butterfly ballot in Palm Beach County, Florida in the 2000 election. Today, there is tremendous variation in how each county conducts its elections. If you move across a county line, your polling place could use an entirely different balloting system. Because here's the really crazy thing about elections in the US.
有些机器可以通过拉动杠杆或使用金属棒从光学扫描选票中戳出孔洞。就像我们在2000年大选佛罗里达州棕榈滩县的蝴蝶选票中所看到的那样。今天，每个县进行选举的方式存在巨大差异。如果你跨越县界，你的投票站可能会使用完全不同的投票系统。因为关于美国的选举，真正疯狂的事情是这样的。
Unlike much of Western Europe, Canada, Australia, South Africa, India, and most other industrialized democracies, the US runs its elections at a hyper-local level. Because the US decentralizes this whole process, you have a patchwork of election procedures all across the country. And it can vary at the county level, or even within some counties, as to how ballots are counted and processed. We do this because that's what the Constitution tells us to do. It says that states shall conduct elections, and the states generally delegate elections down to municipal governments.
与西欧大部分地区、加拿大、澳大利亚、南非、印度和大多数其他工业化民主国家不同，美国在超地方层面举行选举。由于美国将整个过程去中心化，全国各地都有各种各样的选举程序。它可能在县级甚至某些县内部有所不同，关于如何清点和处理选票。我们这样做是因为宪法告诉我们要这样做。它说各州应进行选举，各州通常将选举下放到市级政府。
Partly because voters have so many things to vote for that each municipal government requires its own ballot. We vote for so many public officials. Everything from President to Drain Commissioner can be on a ballot. Yeah, in Michigan, I grew up in Michigan, you can vote for County Drain Commissioner. And so given that each county is responsible for running its own elections, every county is on their own. They could hire a designer to make the ballots, they could not hire a designer to make the ballots. It all depends on what each election's official wants to do.
部分原因是选民要投票的事情太多了，以至于每个市级政府都需要自己的选票。我们为太多的公职人员投票。从总统到排水专员的一切都可能出现在选票上。是的，在密歇根州，我在密歇根州长大，你可以投票选举县排水专员。鉴于每个县都负责组织自己的选举，每个县都是靠自己。他们可以雇佣设计师来制作选票，也可以不雇佣设计师来制作选票。这完全取决于每个选举官员想做什么。
And that, more than malicious intent, may be how Grammar Jeannie and her ilk voted for the wrong guy in 2000. Exactly. Pap Buchanan is a religious fundamentalist kind of guy, not the sort of person that a bunch of Jewish grannies are going to be voting for. If you had tested out this ballot in the kind of pilot test or run what we call a usability test, even with just a few people, that this issue would have surfaced pretty quickly. That's Dana Chiznell. She's a user experience designer. And I do applied research about design in voting in elections.
这可能比恶意更能解释珍妮奶奶和她同类人如何在2000年投错了人。没错。帕特·布坎南是一个宗教原教旨主义者，而不是一群犹太老奶奶会投票的那种人。如果你在某种试点测试中测试过这张选票，或者运行我们所谓的可用性测试，即使只有少数人，这个问题也会很快浮出水面。那是达娜·奇斯内尔。她是一名用户体验设计师。我做关于投票和选举设计的应用研究。
Dana, along with her colleague Whitney Quizenberry with the Center for Civic Design, have made it their mission to bring design theory and practice to elections. In election administration, usability testing doesn't get done. Pilot testing on these kinds of designs doesn't get done. So Dana co-authored a set of field guides to ensure voter intent. Design manuals for elections officials. And the very first one in the series was how to design usable ballots. So one of our recommendations is use lower case letters, use mixed case.
达娜和她在公民设计中心的同事惠特尼·奎森伯里一起，将把设计理论和实践带到选举中作为他们的使命。在选举管理中，可用性测试没有完成。这类设计的试点测试也没有完成。因此，达娜合著了一套现场指南，以确保选民意图。选举官员的设计手册。该系列的第一本是如何设计可用的选票。所以我们的建议之一是使用小写字母，使用大小写混合。
Mixed case print is just easier to read than all caps. This has actually been proven in studies. We also say avoid centered type. Center type is for wedding invitations and wine labels. It really doesn't belong on a form, especially when like this. Other recommendations include using big enough type. In New York in 2012, I think they use six-point type on their ballots.
大小写混合的印刷体比全大写更容易阅读。这实际上已经在研究中得到了证明。我们还说要避免居中排版。居中排版适用于结婚请柬和葡萄酒标签。它真的不属于表格，尤其是像这样的时候。其他建议包括使用足够大的字号。2012年在纽约，我想他们在选票上使用了六号字。
It's not uncommon to find magnifying glasses in New York voting boots. The Center for Civic Design also recommends using one sand serif font. If you look at some of these ballots, they look like ransom notes. There are lots of different type families that are used. The whole thing is just basically screaming at you. And we can calm all that down quite a bit by just going with one...
在纽约的投票亭里发现放大镜并不罕见。公民设计中心还建议使用一种无衬线字体。如果你看看其中一些选票，它们看起来像勒索信。使用了许多不同的字体族。整个事情基本上在对你尖叫。我们可以通过只使用一种...
...sensor of... font. The suggestions of the guidebooks for how to design a good ballot are akin to designing a good anything. When designers get a hold of these things, they're like, This is design 101. But election officials don't know this. And election officials, unlike normal clients, often have to uphold legislation requiring them
...无衬线...字体来让这一切平静下来。指导手册关于如何设计一张好选票的建议类似于设计任何好东西。当设计师掌握了这些东西时，他们会觉得，这是设计101。但选举官员不知道这一点。而且选举官员与普通客户不同，通常必须维护要求他们
to use bad design. If you go look at election code in practically every state, thing, design of the ballot is legislated. What the typeface is, what size it should be, what the grid is. It's like bad design is legislated. Oh yeah, almost exclusively bad design. So not only do election officials have to apply better design
使用糟糕设计的立法。如果你去查看几乎每个州的选举法，事情是，选票的设计是立法规定的。字体是什么，尺寸应该是多少，网格是什么。就像糟糕的设计被立法了一样。哦，是的，几乎全是糟糕的设计。所以选举官员不仅要应用更好的设计
principles to their ballot making, they also need to change laws. But one thing that might solve ballots for good is standardizing them. It's actually a project which Dana, Chisnell, and the Center for Civic Design are also working on. They've developed a prototype called the Anywhere Ballot.
原则到他们的选票制作中，他们还需要修改法律。但有一件事可能会彻底解决选票问题，那就是标准化。这实际上是达娜·奇斯内尔和公民设计中心也在进行的一个项目。他们开发了一个名为“随处投票”的原型。
It's a touchscreen system where you can resize text, adjust contrast, navigately, verify that you've voted for who you meant to vote for, and it's open source, so any elections official can use it. Though Dana is quick to admit that it probably won't eliminate all forms of unfairness. Oh, well something always goes wrong, I just hope that it will not be a major design disaster. The election official's prayer is, may the margins be wide.
这是一个触摸屏系统，你可以在其中调整文本大小、调整对比度、导航、验证你是否为你打算投票的人投了票，而且它是开源的，所以任何选举官员都可以使用它。尽管达娜很快承认它可能不会消除所有形式的不公平。哦，总会有出错的时候，我只希望它不会成为重大设计灾难。选举官员的祈祷是，愿票差很大。
May the margins be wide. Find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
愿票差很大。了解有关这个故事的更多信息，包括精美的图片和链接，并收听99% Invisible的所有剧集。你必须去9pi.org。塔皮奥广播电台。来自PRX。你本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子发表评论。